this is a really interesting story in
Indiana college has come under fire for
refusing to oust a tenured professor for
sharing racist homophobic and sexist
posts on social media Indiana University
Bloomington sited professor Eric
Rasmussen First Amendment rights in its
decision the outrage followed a tweet
Rasmussen sent out this month it was a
quote from an article that said in part
geniuses are overwhelmingly male he
included a link to the article titled
are women
destroying academia probably in a letter
to the students the school's Provo
strongly condemned Rasmussen posts and
called them stunningly ignorant she says
Rasmussen has also shared that women and
gay men do not belong in academia and
that black students are quote inferior
academically to white students Matheson
says those claims are an exaggeration of
his beliefs academic freedom should
protect me even if I believed all the
things the Provost attributed to me I
think I should be able to quote from an
article without saying I agree with
everything in the article so you know
the school probe also wrote we cannot
nor would we fire professor Rasmussen
first post as a private citizen as vile
and stupid as they are because the First
Amendment of the United States
Constitution
they are allowing students to not enroll
in his classes however transfer out of
his classes which is the way that they
can produce I'm just thinking if you
were a student in that class you were
gay student a woman a person of color I
would think that would be very
uncomfortable knowing if he allegedly
believes the things that he's posted
yeah I mean academic freedom is one
thing but what he's saying is not
academic at all yeah what city has
control over your grades yeah there's a
problem